Earlier, I mentioned that in addition to its schemas,
OpenAM Health provides useful tools.
One of these might be of particular interest to students of this course.
It allows users to specify a dataset they want generated using YAML,
a data serialization language designed to be
both human-readable and computationally powerful.
This example asks for body weights over
a particular date range and with specified starting and end values,
standard deviation, and minimum and maximum values.
OpenAM Health also provides a library of
visualization tools to use once the data is generated.
This example, plots both minutes of physical activity
and step counts and is scrollable to vary the time period covered.
Earlier, I mentioned Human API and Validic,
two companies that offer
their own proprietary platforms for integrating AM health data from multiple sources.
OpenAM Health has developed Shimmer,
an open source tool to pull health data from popular third-party APIs,
like Runkeeper and Fitbit,
and convert it into an OpenAM Health-compliant format.
The tool is of obvious benefit to app developers since,
somewhat similarly to FHIR,
it allows them to develop independently of the underlying data source.
Currently, the number of data sources is small compared to the commercial platforms,
but OpenAM Health says it is working to add more.
It also offers Pulse to map HL7 messages from EHRs into OpenAM Health's schema.